miles de años de historias arrasados en
menos de dos minutos
el terremoto que sacudió Turquía y Siria
ha dañado miles de edificios incluido
este Castillo desgaste un lugar
histórico y una atracción turística en
el sureste de Turquía
el sismo derribó a los muros del
castillo y provocó grandes grietas en
los bastiones las autoridades locales
esperan restaurar el emblemático
castillo construido por el rey Romano en
los siglos XIII
el castillo de la ciudad es la
estructura más importante que Define su
identidad es una de las estructuras más
valiosas y significativas para nosotros
una vez realizados los estudios y
métodos técnicos comenzarán las obras de
restauración se crearán fondos para
apoyar el proceso de restauración que se
espera que dure muchos años
Mientras tanto en Antioquia una antigua
mezquita está ahora en ruinas
a unos cientos de metros una de las
iglesias más antiguas del mundo también
ha desaparecido
la ciudad ha sufrido varios terremotos
casi uno cada 100 años y no es ajena la
reconstrucción pero sus habitantes temen
que pase mucho tiempo antes de que se
recupere de este y que su identidad
histórica única nunca se recupere del
todo
pasarán 10 años antes de que puedan
reconstruir la ciudad la ciudad ha
desaparecido Eso es todo se necesita
mucho tiempo y mucho dinero
Turquía y Siria se consideran cunas de
las civilización humana y ambas albergan
varios lugares declarados patrimonio de
la humanidad por la UNESCO entre ellos
la antigua ciudad de alepo ya devastada
por la guerra civil Siria